i mean you are running against a very
wealthy senator and
also uh raphael warnock running against
the wealthiest
uh senator in the whole entire u.s
senate um
what's your message to republicans if
their message and donald trump's message
is you know don't vote um what's your
message to republicans in your state
right now what would you tell them
um about the security uh concerns they
have in the election should they vote
and come vote for you
well i want everyone to participate in
our democracy
and my message for republican voters my
message for all voters
is that we got two senators who are like
the bonnie and clyde of political
corruption in washington
david perdue lives on a private island
and treats his senate office like it's
his e-trade account
kelly leffler's family literally owns
the company that owns the new york stock
exchange and she was cashing out of a
stock market the same day she got
a private briefing on kobit 19. it's not
about democrats and republicans this is
about the people
against crooks who are using their
offices to enrich themselves at a moment
of national tragedy
while they obstruct relief for ordinary
people
because the same senators who are
getting rich because they have access to
privileged information
are holding up now for months the kinds
of support that regular people need the
stimulus checks that folks need the
small business support that folks need
i mean they have no concept of how badly
people are hurting
and we need swift passage now in the
senate
of a relief bill
in public uh senator perdue has been
unwilling
so far to acknowledge that joe biden won
the election
uh but he did uh and in private though
uh he made a little bit of a different
comment about joe biden but the
washington post
got a quote of it so let's take a listen
to that
if we can keep the majority in the
senate we can at least be a buffer on
some of the things that the the biden
camp has been talking about in terms of
foreign policy
that sure sounds pretty different than
what he's saying in public what's your
reaction to the fact that
i mean he seems to be acknowledging
reality in private
yeah i mean in public david perdue is
saying one thing and it's
for the president's ears and it's
because he's living in
fear that donald trump will abandon him
and in private when he's speaking to
donors and probably a lot of these
donors are like never trump republicans
who didn't support the president in the
first place he's acknowledging something
like reality and he's throwing the
president under the bus and saying that
the president's underperformance here is
what dragged down republicans in georgia
this year
so david perdue is trying to balance his
desperate need for the president's
affection and support
with some urge to acknowledge reality
the bottom line is that in the midst of
a crisis like this
for them to be focused on how they
grapple with the president's temper
tantrum over losing
is such a nonsense distraction because
we've now lost more than a quarter of a
million americans
to this virus we got homes and jobs and
businesses on the line
working families who can't make the car
payment and the house payment and afford
the health care they need
joblessness growing by the day and this
is what they're spending their time on
it makes no sense it's totally out of
touch with what ordinary
working georgians care about and need
absolutely and and the people in georgia
are definitely in need in this pandemic
as
are so many americans